welcome back to Long crime daily we head
now to Wisconsin where the defendant in
the Waukesha Christmas parade trial
Daryl Brooks goes on a nearly hour-long
rant as he represents himself against
his six murder charges for allegedly
driving his SUV into parade goers last
year
court on Thursday began early with
discussions over Brooks's witness
subpoenas an argument over him being
called Daryl Brooks he identifies as a
sovereign Citizen and has claimed
several times he does not recognize his
name the proceedings moved on to witness
testimony from a woman who was part of
the dancing grannies four of whom were
killed during the tragedy amid her
testimony the jury was excused for
another legal discussion the judge
addressed Brook's repeated request for
stating the grounds for overruling his
objections then Brooks went on a
50-minute ran saying he's been treated
unfairly and as to the case be dismissed
he said he didn't have adequate time to
prepare ahead of trial to which the
state had an opportunity to respond
if I'm not in the courtroom or sleeping
I should be awarded the time to work on
this case seeing this how
I only had a couple days to prepare for
a trial of this magnitude Mr Brooks
knowingly willingly voluntarily and
intelligently
insisted on representing himself in this
trial now he's here complaining over and
over and over again how unfair this is
to him he is not going into this blind
or with one arm tied behind his back
they did all the homework
Lisa what's your reaction to Brooks's
ranting have you ever seen these kind of
arguments actually be successful
uh if my personal experience no what
happens with self-representation is this
a lot of times you don't have the legal
training to even come close to a defense
attorneys you're unable to contain your
anger there's oftentimes false bravado
and it frustrates the judge and the jury
the statistics on somebody actually
winning a case is about 10 to 14 percent
when they represent themselves and a lot
of those times these are attorneys
representing themselves so he doesn't
really stand a chance yeah it doesn't
know the basics of objections or
arguments and he probably has an
attorney helping him but I think we
refer to as a jailhouse attorney and not
the greatest of information Terry you've
said you would have not allowed Daryl
Brooks to represent himself why is that
you know I have said that from all along
and listen I absolutely positively
respect judge Darrow's patience I
respect her decision but the Supreme
Court has held that the sixth amendment
in addition to guaranteeing the right to
counsel also guarantees the defendant
the right to represent himself and
that's why she allowed it she questioned
him repeatedly and basically she found
that he was knowingly and intelligently
waving his right but if in fact he is
disruptive the court has also said that
that right can be curtailed and there's
no question from the very beginning he
was disruptive he was delaying he had
all of these tactics and essentially if
I had been the judge from the beginning
I would have said no and she would have
had the right to do that she doesn't
have to allow him to waste the time of
the Court essentially What's Happening
Here is Brooks is making a mockery of
the system he's making a mockery of her
courtroom even though I think she's
doing a great job at trying to Reign him
in she shouldn't have to work so hard
the jury shouldn't have to listen to all
of that and we should essentially be
able to proceed forward without having
to be delayed time and time again with
his Antics now Terry quick real quick
just to clarify when you say no are you
saying no to him not being able to waive
his sixth amendment right and to
represent himself or no to the
continuous and continuous outbreaks that
he's making in court or both well I was
just gonna say both Brian I absolutely
would have said no from the very
beginning because while she was doing
that questioning if you remember he was
giving her a hard time and she was
barely able to get him to answer he
talked about his name he kept saying I
don't understand I'm not agreeing I have
been informed from that very beginning I
would have said to myself had I been
sitting on that bench I don't think this
is going to go well I think he's going
to be disruptive I don't necessarily
think he is knowingly and intelligently
waving his right to counsel because he's
having all of these discussions about
well I'm informed well what does that
mean does that mean you understand does
that mean you agree I think she had the
basis for denying it but she was airing
on the side of caution she wanted to
give him the opportunity and she did
exactly that and I can't falter for that
interesting by that analysis this might
come back on appeal and he might get a
public defender but we'll see how that
works out thank you for joining us here
on Lawton crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America